jenny hold up look i brought a disc and
we could copy this
okay no problem all we got to do is
whoa
don't copy don't copy that fluffy
stealing what's not yours is that really
where you want your life to go
but they can't stop people from coughing
it's too easy
it might be easy but it's still against
the law don't copy
don't copy that floppy
[Music]
around the mid-2000s post napster
music piracy was still a huge problem
at the time it was all torrents
everybody had moved to torrance that's
how most people were
sort of young people at least were
getting their music online piracy
is costing the u.s film industry 20
billion dollars a year like don't they
know they can download that stuff for
free
use bittorrent the question
is what's the best way to fight the riaa
hack of them 98 shame on you people
the music industry was preoccupied with
the whole
peer-to-peer file transfer illegal theft
it had to figure out how it was going to
attack
and approach the marketplace in this new
world to be able to remain viable and
competitive
to us it's black and white and you pay
for it you straight up and down and
stealing
[Music]
sweden out of all the countries in the
world had adopted
pirate technology more than anywhere
else
it was a country full of hackers they'd
come up with all different kind of takes
on
peer-to-peer networks and bittorrent and
they had the pirate party
the entire political party that really
traces its roots back to napster
[Applause]
for them trading music it's like a
political
cultural calling
[Music]
the swedish parts of the music industry
they were suffering even more than
maybe their american counterparts very
few people
were buying cds anymore or very few
people were buying licensed material
online everyone was using the file
sharing networks
at that time there was a guy named
daniel eck who was swedish
who had previously been the ceo of a
torrent company
and he said i have a plan to make people
pay
for music again we're going to move
beyond the locally stored mp3 file
into the kind of like globally
distributed stream
that was his business model which he
calls spotify
what if instead of you know having to go
through the trouble of you know buying
and downloading music what if they
had access to all the music in the world
[Music]
just through a streaming service
spotify launched in sweden in october
2008.
spotify took off in sweden and so ek was
able to go around to different countries
and get and get the labels there to do
the same thing and eventually he came to
the u.s
[Music]
daniel's he's not steve jobs
[Music]
he's very soft-spoken you can tell that
he's kind of a nerdy
engineer he's very polite and
easy-going and for the labels i think
daniel being not as abrasive
and scary and powerful as steve jobs was
probably
pretty attractive and the thought
of him sitting in a room with all these
music execs and
and banging his fist on the table is
hard for me to imagine
but he's the one who talks all of these
labels into cooperating
and giving the service that he made a
chance
spotify they presented us with an option
now
we can say we don't want to use it we
don't want to distribute that way
but we'll be like dinosaurs and we
wouldn't be here
the mistakes the major record labels
made in the late 90s
i will give them credit for this they
learned from those mistakes and they
understood that they had to scramble to
get ahead of the next wave of technology
europe's best kept secret is out in the
open spotify has landed in the usa
and with 10 million registered users in
europe it could be a big hit here
the unlimited service is ad-free but
locked your computer
while the premium service brings spotify
to your mobile devices
you're like hey you want to hear this
new song all you have to do is go boom
it's right there
wait a minute everything's here like
everything just like the first time i
used an mp3 i said oh my god i'm never
going to pay again
the first time i use spotify i was like
i'm gonna pay again aren't i
and so that's how well it worked
from about the turn of the century until
three or four years ago
the music industry had lost around 40 of
its entire value
physical sales are pretty much over but
streaming's growing growing growing
next thing you know google amazon
microsoft
apple they all want to have a streaming
subscription service good morning today
we're announcing
apple music today i'm happy to announce
google play music
all access amazon is taking the plunge
diving into an already crowded streaming
market with a new subscription music
service
some big names behind a streaming music
service being relaunched now with some
help from jay-z
he bought title for 56 million dollars
in january
we've reached a point where there are
too many streaming options to mention
companies ran away from music because
there wasn't any growth now there is
that's a sign that the industry's
becoming healthy you know after years of
being you know really sick
it's just a question of what it means
for artists
for microsoft google apple
music doesn't mean something special to
them it's just something that gets
bundled along
in this monthly fee that you pay for
various things whereas
obviously this is the lifeblood for
musicians
streaming has a lot of business
challenges attached to it the whole
notion of
micro pennies you could have hundreds of
thousands of streams and you get paid 12
cents
people can't even tell me what a stream
is worth this
just changes from month to month to
month to month to month no one knows how
to quantify
as far as online streaming the record
companies
they take whatever their percentage is
everyone gets a cut
what's left of that we have to split
four ways and
with our manager so it's literally
nothing you know
the artists are looking at these tenth
of a cent royalties and going that's
crazy
do you know how many times someone have
to listen to that song or those groups
of songs to be equivalent to what i'd
make from an album sale
tonight word of a music smackdown taylor
swift is pulling her music
off of spotify and all of this over
pricing
in an editorial she wrote file sharing
and streaming
have shrunk the numbers of paid album
sales drastically
valuable things should be paid for i saw
like what taylor swift just did
and i think that's awesome i mean the
only person really getting screwed here
is the artist and that's the way it
always is
why don't they pay taylor swift more why
don't they pay ari the rugged man more
taylor don't need the money as much as
me but she's got a good point
everybody's doing the work then they
need to get paid
just that simple i need my money
so you had some artists speaking out
rihanna released a new single last week
she's one of the partners of title you
can't stream it on spotify but you can
stream it exclusively on title
in reality they're all coming back
the other week taylor swift decided to
once again offer her entire back catalog
on spotify
with streaming it's the way that the
music industry is going so
we're all gonna have to figure out a way
to make it work
when people are bitching they're not
making enough money they have to
understand
if you're a successful artist today you
can make
more money than you've ever made in the
history of the music business
there are sponsorships and you can do
ads
in addition concert revenues exceed by a
huge margin what they used to
so you have to look at all the
opportunities not only from these
streaming services
yeah you get pennies on the dollar
whatever who cares go out there and play
a show
and make money and get out there and do
that don't complain about an internet
streaming service that's so lame
cry me a river
[Music]
through this entire period of time while
the recorded music industry's been down
the live music industry has been
flourishing and
there's maybe an easy explanation in a
world where
we get less and less personal online
the precious thing is seeing it live and
experiencing it because you can't
digitize
experience the digital age makes it a
lot easier to scout talent i would say
we're able to get data and metrics from
all sorts of different
sites whether that's spotify listener
data on the publicly available
about the artist page there's usually
about 40 percent we see
of their monthly listeners in a certain
city
would actually purchase tickets to that
show in that city
i think now your recording is an
advertisement
for your performance and your live
engagement not the other way around
[Music]
touring touring is non-stop revenue
all year that's where all the money
comes from
i'll talk till i'm dead i'll tour till
i'm dead
[Music]
it shouldn't be that you have to be a
touring act
touring is grueling we don't want to
tour all the time you know it's we're
getting older and it's
a lot of hard work being out there doing
that but those are things you have to do
i think i make the most of my majority
of my money from shows it wasn't always
like that but it's like that now
merch is probably next
i didn't think i'd be a t-shirt merchant
when i was
started making music these are socks
these go
really quickly especially at shows this
is a raincoat
it has the hot sugar castle i have
shirts i have afro hoodies i have this
afro shirt right here
this is a t-shirt another t-shirt with
another picture of me
you cannot to my knowledge download a
shirt
this is a front and back hat this is
bahala java
it's a brand of coffee that zach wilde
created
i'm telling you you can clean your house
about five times mow the lawn three
times
even though it's already finished the
first time you mow it and that's before
brunch
and it is one of the best selling
coffees on amazon
you have to as an artist make products
that are
sellable because music
not as sellable as it used to be
where records had always been by far the
majority of the income
earned by people who made albums
increasingly
artists were making more money from
touring from live events and
ticketing and merchandising emails and
they really were earning from their
records
our revenue model didn't make any sense
any longer
let me ask you something i want to have
some fun tonight
i was offered really deals in my life
and it got to the point where i hated my
label
so i said hey i'm going to run and do
this myself
and when i started doing independent
records that's when all my money started
coming in and that's where all my
success started coming in and that's
where all of my fans started coming in
chance the rapper has gone from making
mixtapes in his south south chicago home
to winning three grammys and performing
for the president at the white house
all without the backing of a single
record label more artists have been
making more music at home
and releasing it themselves in into
streaming services so it's a it's been a
creative renaissance
we're now going to be rolling out the
ability to monetize directly on
soundcloud we're inviting hundreds of
thousands of creators
this means more money in their pocket at
the end of the day on a revenue share
basis
thousands of people are making money off
their talents and hobbies with patreon
patreon is a lot like kickstarter but
it's ongoing it's per music video i
upload band camp is this website where
artists can
independently just take the music that
they produce themselves
and put it up onto the website an artist
uploads their music to bandcamp
a fan pays them directly for it we take
a small cut it's about half of what
itunes charges bandcamp has become
the hero i think that they are more
closely attuned to listening to
the needs of musicians and actually
meeting those concrete needs
it's better than i think virtually any
other company that's out there
they've really provided an online record
store
and a way for artists to recoup
money and i haven't seen any other
company try to meet those needs
if you've got merchandise if you've got
physical cds
if you've got t-shirts and hats and all
sorts of stuff like that
you can sell that directly on the
bandcamp platform as well
can't do that on spotify or apple music
[Music]
now to another grim milestone the world
surpassing one million deaths from the
coronavirus
i don't think we were prepared for the
realization
that the majority of our livelihood
depended on
us being on the road all the time and
physically being at shows
[Music]
most artists today who are successful
are making majority of their income
through live performance
60 70 sometimes upwards of 80
of an artist's income is reliant on
touring on merchandise
on on this which is empty
a little more than a month before
they're scheduled to be in california
variety reports bts cancelled shows in
seoul korea due to fear
over the spread of the virus more than
40 percent of canadians wouldn't feel
comfortable going to a music event
until at least six months after social
restrictions are lifted
the shutdown of live shows this year has
affected me
in so many different ways i have been
turning to live streaming i'm on twitch
every week i've built up a nice little
community i've got a discord going i'm
doing the whole thing
let go let go look we about to get it
wrecking in this
you just tuned into the latest channel
on twitch
in a major collaboration that's clearly
a sign of times
12 million players locked into fortnite
last night to watch a virtual travis
scott perform in concert
[Applause]
it's great for the artists it's great
for the fans and that's something i
think that you're going to see more of
after the pandemic is people not wanting
to just see
a show at a venue in a theater and
you'll want to see
more and more experiences and less and
less just pure concerts
everybody on youtube subscribe twitch
you subscribe
what facebook do you like and subscribe
to let's go
make sure you subscribe make sure you
smash the subscribe button on youtube
thank you guys for donating even if you
didn't have the means to donate thank
you for tuning in
i've had a music career just by going
straight to
consumers into an audience and fans
rather than
waiting for this faceless music industry
guy to help pitch it you didn't do
nothing i did all the hard work
so why shouldn't i make 100 of that
money
what's up guys hi guys welcome back to
the channel
zoom in i want to see you i got my
screen right up here i can watch you
guys
interaction is everything for me
something that's really unique with
live streaming is that you actually get
to know the names of your fans and you
get to know their
their personal lives big hearts
up for big cheese right now cause he
needs all love man he was he was down
for a little second
dude shout out to savannah bibo sparky
miss winter falcon you guys are legends
legends your fans get to actually
chat with you live and give input as far
as what they want to hear
so the revolution will be televised
but there really is nothing like being
on stage
with tens of thousands of people in
front of you
at a festival with the lights and
everybody's screaming
i just miss it all
i don't think streaming is the end of
the game i think the game will continue
to unfold
you as a talented artist you can go make
your own recording
you can build your career using social
media
and the major labels role in creating
the next generation of successful
artists
will become less and less important
we found out that the record companies
are limited
it's like okay you're taking but what
you're giving back you're giving me a
piece of my soul back to me
or you're just taking my soul and
keeping it and cashing it in
if you've only got a niche audience it
doesn't make sense
to sign to a major label right now more
than ever
the law of a thousand true fans is what
we're going to see
working as a model going forward you
could have
10 million plays on your song on spotify
but that doesn't mean that you're going
to sell 100 tickets to a show
1 000 true fans can sustain you if you
have the right platforms in place and
that can be anything from band camp
to patreon to twitch any of these places
that are meant
to build community and allow you to have
a space
that you control where you can sell
virtually anything about your creative
process that you want
most people who aren't on a major label
want to be a lot of the diy guys once
they start to kind of
you know blow up they go to the label
[Music]
the weekend is a perfect example he did
these kind of brilliant albums in his
bedroom they got massive radio play
after he gave him away for free
but then he went to the major label when
the time came
labels definitely have a place but
they're not
the gatekeepers anymore you don't have
to sign to
a major record label to be successful in
the music business anymore
you know and thank god for that
stand clear of the closing doors please
[Music]
the mp3 is now an obsolete technology
by 1998 there were more sophisticated
replacements available
but the core of what it did lives on
whenever you're streaming music via your
phone
it's using the same techniques that
brandenburg pioneered back in the 80s
people are walking around with their
internet connected phones
and they're just listening to music all
the time and it couldn't be easier
so finally we have this thing that
everybody's been talking about
literally for you know 20 years the
celestial jukebox
and people are listening to more music
than they ever have in history
[Music]
if you go to the roots of the mobile
computing revolution
it's based on mp3 piracy
the idea of walking into an apple store
and spending three or four hundred
dollars on a gadget
you had to get primed by the mp3 to want
to do that
ultimately i think the mp3 created more
value
than it destroyed yesterday apple
reported the largest quarterly profit
of any public company in history
a lot of money was made along the way
just not by the people who used to make
it
the fundamental way that companies make
money has completely changed the first
time
an mp3 was moved from one person to the
next
generations from that point forward have
realized access to things
is more valuable than owning them
why own a car when i can call uber
anytime
why own a second home when i can go to
airbnb
if i can have access and hear any song
when i want why own a cd
[Music]
the march of technology is a good thing
not a bad thing
the fact that it uniquely affected us
was the way of life really
nowadays i love to listen to
classical music i love some of the newer
music
what about rap music oh yeah why not
talking about mp3 i had the feeling
this is not good for the music industry
but in the end
i think it changed for the better
you